We human beings diligently scan the night
sky hoping to find something new, and every
now and then keeping an open ear pays off.
In 2007 astronomers detected a sudden blast
of radio waves that lasted just a few milliseconds
and dubbed it a Fast Radio Burst.
Since then they’ve found about two dozen
more, but one in particular has them intrigued.
Speaking of being intrigued though, have you
visited our friend Simon at Today I Found
Out?
If you’re watching Seeker you obviously
like learning new things, so definitely check
out Simon’s channel -- Today I Found Out
-- because that is what it’s all about!
There’s a link in the description to this
video about the dogs we launched into space,
FOR SCIENCE.
Okay, back to the fast radio bursts.
The source is called FRB 121102, so called
because it was first observed on November
second, 2012.
The reason FRB 121102 is special is because
sometimes it repeats, the only Fast Radio
Burst we’ve found that does so.
Knowing that it pipes up from time to time,
astronomers have paid close attention to FRB
121102’s patch of sky, and sure enough on
August 26, 2017, they detected 15 MORE bursts,
bringing the total number to over 150.
No one’s sure exactly what causes these
fast radio bursts.
It’s possible they’re generated by a young
and fast spinning neutron star with an intense
magnetic field.
Or maybe, just maybe, it’s aliens and they’re
sending out a hailing frequency and we’re
gonna be best friends and go on kickass adventures.
*jumping freeze frame* on take 3
I’m sorry I just get really excited when
something might be aliens.
But in truth it’s a pretty distant possibility.
Like, really distant.
Since FRB 121102 repeats we’ve been able
to figure out where it’s coming from, a
dwarf galaxy 3 billion light years away.
That means if it IS aliens, they sent the
signal 3 billion years ago, when life on Earth
was just single celled organisms.
Any reply wouldn’t get back to them for
another 3 billion years.
If these aliens haven’t died out, they’ve
probably forgotten they even called.
I bet they moved on with their lives, got
married, started a family, evolved into completely
different life forms with 60 tentacles, that
sort of thing.
Fast radio bursts may be more common than
we thought, with some astronomers estimating
that one goes off somewhere in the universe
every second.
So either they’re just some as-yet-unexplained
and totally mundane phenomenon, or there are
a lot of life forms out there trying to reach
out and touch someone with their 60 gelatinous
arms.
Either way, we’ll keep listening to find
out.
Remember to subscribe to Seeker for more videos
and to check out Simon on Today I Found Out
to learn why we sent dogs into space!
It had to be ruff for them.
You know?
That was horrible.
With all this talk about aliens we can’t
forget that an asteroid flew through our solar
system and of course, some people thought
IT was aliens too.
But it wasn’t.
This video explains why. Thanks again for watching.